so hetero is building better predictions
and focused on building a math engine in
the open source and bring really
state-of-the-art distributed at all
gardens for big data and very classic of
course looks great yeah if you're low
man and one change bug you are also
hiring so far the math or systems
hackers looking for a QA white box
testers people a lot of numbers and the
impact of math is actually substantial
you're seeing fraction across different
different verticals in vertically not
top part about or parts of the source
free curve cancer research before it's
all the column before it's all to us and
that's a very a very young started we
get a set up well funded but our focus
is to be a patient lecture legacy that's
what if is massive opportunity and
there's not a playa scientist so wasting
here sigh sigh this time is like wasting
really like regulate your vote the world
never had enough mathematicians and in a
given time because we can pop them today
as well that's kind of why that's the
focus of this this era of your range of
the tools so like daily life of big
things get better and eventually you'd
only expected analyst or business on the
sterile coat and so we want to make sure
there's not a lot of mass-produced be
cloned and to higher levels rather have
mathematicians get closer to business
and solve real domain problems at the
highest level what we do can be seven
three pieces exploration modeling and
scoring and expiration is mostly a top
exploration that's where the language
piece comes in modeling is mostly about
math and so that's where our key focus
pretty company in the product key and
Ellie's and real-time scoring is kind of
the very velocity comes into play so at
the highest speeds we are building a
better exploration through our you can
actually use your existing API that our
Python and JSON to drive our part and we
are working with messy data try to help
with missing elements and bring better
data exploration up front where munging
day to day 10 and between tools going
between different Linux consoles and
MapReduce jobs let stand where you're
going to actually give you very easy
experience one single through and then
further we focus on bullying very good
high scale regression of Gotham's
classification algorithms and clustering
algorithms you can see random forests
from the team classification
speak another power engineering we have
a very good implementation that will ask
you to try it and see how it solves your
problems fundamentally the real problem
here is probably to solve unbalanced
dear friends how do you actually make
sure you can find the need of the case
egg and a static on sobe last day we
actually are also coming optimization
problem of our customers so that's also
part of our roadmap you want to give you
the formula again math modeling toolkit
that you can take any size business and
any size machines and scoring which is
actually kind of a low latency element
of the space where you want to take
these models and put them introduction
and makeup still go very fast right so
low latency it's kind of a shock so you
can do hundreds of these models in a
very very quick fashion so there's no
one model for all of your caregiver and
we want you to be able to use multiple
models and the only way to do that is
for engine is redefined and so that's
that we have a hundred nanoseconds
coding in change that embeds into
whatever system that your premises
Mozart and so you can actually take that
to production till your policy offline
scoring it's as good as your own minds
for it you can you have more confidence
taking your market so you have a
fantastic team that puts all these three
together very different pieces one of
them with language other giving with
data and
and then malignancy all this is about
forcing an annual a peon you don't want
the world it's not language is already
and it's going to be a volleyball for it
so let's embrace it we would take your
languages and then make them scale
sometimes are we have a future for their
pasta our project of yawns also
everything that our tastes are impudent
but escapes it on white coat of java the
other big piece that has been a concern
is more than a better or better balance
better and different camps in this in
the valley as well across India are one
of the things that we we want to stomp
is you don't have to make a choice you
get more data and bread or buttons
alright so you think the best ladies
algorithm so we're actually one of the
future roadmap easily GBM that you're
taking trying to scale it on dictator
other piece of you people will kinetic
about Boltzmann machines and stuff in
time so here trying to take these new
legislative algorithms applied in that
scale so it's not just more data or
petrol bottoms technical and solve the
problems and so the real real key piece
is not necessarily a lot until next step
or you discover insights in your ear
finally we don't you not get another
beginners start up trying to make money
here trying to leave an intellectual
legacy piece we really believe that math
needs to be free and it's tens of
thousands of years of evolutionary
knowledge and that needs to be a
platform that anybody can access and
will get better tools and applications
on top of the core math platform and
that's why we are we are actually a very
open source company
and we want for the great community as
well as community of users delivers
extenders build applications you want to
support you guys to go use the math on
the fundamental discovered one of the
shocking discovery that we had a company
or there's not enough math being Jews in
the businesses in enterprises in the
world and that's something you were here
out to change we were trying to evaluate
and going to all these new jobs talking
directly to end users is one of the core
philosophy so you picked up and we are
trying to vandalize use a better math
and use a better technologies for
solving your big day problems and so
that's a firm is open we're going to
make its apache me to license we expect
people to it eventually we're going to
become a plastic apache software
foundation but you want to make sure we
get to high velocity before we get into
it so fantastic king you're hiring but
our team of very solid systems engineers
but also very good data science advisor
symbolic Trevor Casey as objects Ronnie
and you put the source but whoever has
invented the technology that algorithm
you're going to gun straight and asking
them what a better way to do it all
right take your Fortran implementation
so it scales better how do we take that
and apply for a very highly unbalanced
dataset and that's kind of the real
heart of the problem is how do we take
this gray algorithms in RN and
implementations not make them widely
accessible to a great audience and
that's kind of
the core is intended for us is an
algorithm that was devised originally by
leo breiman and adele coupler a few
years back it synthesizes a number of
ideas that we're floating in the
community now we'll start by introducing
a few of the key concepts so you can
understand the rest of the talk and I'll
you know and try to be our self
contained as possible so starting with
the beginnings we'll start by describing
what is a classification tree so imagine
you have a very simple data set scoop
it's composed of red and green dots
there they are living on a plane to the
surface with coordinates in X ranging
from 1 to 4 and Y from five to eight
okay simple enough and imagine that the
goal or we set ourselves is given a new
observation pick a color that gonna be
red or bring right if you look at the
board you know some patterns may emerge
it's not completely random so how are we
going to decide what our color to assign
to our new observation well one way to
do this is a to be to build a
classification tree so instance here's
one that I've built for you and
basically
he says things like this if if your
x-axis is so let's start at the root is
larger than three and your y-axis is
larger than six that's this corner
you're going to get red and basically
what the tree does is it describes
knowing the this this chessboard in fine
granularity so that every point you know
every point is is identified by some
leaf node in the tree and all the leaf
node have a single color and therefore
now if I come with a new observation I
can just figure out in which node it
will fall and say ah you know it's
rather easy enough so another way to
visualize the tree is to think of the
tree as painting the surface with these
colors and wherever you land in the 2d
space this is the color you will get how
the obvious thing is it's the first
thing that comes to mind when you think
about it a little bit is that you know
this is just one small sample of the
population and of this this painting
here doesn't quite match our intuition
if you go back one thing you know
darling tuition if you look at this
point distance is roughly that these
squares are red these squares are green
roughly set but if you look at the
painting you know you have this whole
Bank here that shows up as green so what
we're doing is we're over fitting the
little data we have to generate
you know this classic fire correct so
the idea of random forest is really
simple it's you know we start with the
original population and to avoid
overfitting you're going to build many
trees but many partial trees many trees
that are kind of wrong but the idea is
you know if you put a lots of people who
are kind of thrown together you get
American democracy or ready for a
starter ah let's see so how do we do
this well we take without take our
original population and then we're going
to sample it get subsets of that
original population and for each of
those subsets so these are two subsets
they are slight they're overlapping
right they can have the same observation
from each of those subsets we're going
to build ourselves a tree using exactly
the same approach as before so here's a
tree for one subset and here's a tree
for another subset and the interesting
thing about those trees is there will be
point where they disagree you know this
this point here I'm saying that things
that are in that corner when I would see
larger than three larger than three
smaller
so I forget what I was doing but there
will be points which which is agree why
because you have different you know
different populations and is this square
for instance in this tree has only a
green dot so it's a safe assumption that
you'll classify this baseless green
whereas this square happens to have only
red dot so it's a safe assumption that
you're classified as described but the
thing is that by randomizing and seeing
only some small part of the population
we are going to create a combined
classifier that it performs better so
the parts were the three agree we're
really sure about the parts where they
disagree you know it's you know it's up
for grabs okay so there are couple more
things to introduce about a random
forest so this concept of of taking
random samples is called biking
basically the idea is each tree will be
built on a different subset of the
population that you take without
replacement from the original and then
that's a very simple thing and then the
second concept is oh how do I grow by
trees well I'll grow by three spy at
each node selecting of the splits this
value of one of the feature that bests
separates my population and you have
different criteria such as genie or
information game make sure you talk to
the to do this and then you keep on
growing the trees until either
hit a limit or you get leaf nodes that
are you know uniform in one population
then once you have a set of trees what
the way you use them is 4-h no
observation you will simply vote you'll
say I have this new point I'll classify
it with which trees and i'll pick know
if sixty percent say red i'll say red
simple enough oh there's a couple more
more small things to talk about one is
the notion of error so Brian had this
very elegant way to evaluate the quality
of a forest this is what he pulled out
of bag error and basically the idea is
as follows each time we build a tree so
we pick a sample of the population and
we're going to use that sample to build
a tree what we're going to do is
remember all the observation we did not
use to build that tree and use those
observations to evaluate that particular
tree so you'll a 103 they're built with
hundred samples and they're evaluated
with hundred compliments of those
samples so for instance if I build a
tree with this this sample and I
evaluate it with this one I'll get most
likely errors around here because here I
only so green and the compliment has red
and here because I only so red and there
was a green dot okay so out of whack
error is this error estimates that you
can use without any special data you can
use it you can create an estimate
using the same data you used to train
and build your model and lastly how do
we know what how well we're doing well
at the end of the day you will have a
validation set say and you will build
yourself a confusion matrix of this kind
which says well you know I've predicted
that 15 observations you are red but you
know there were an five greens and this
is your assigned research actual and
this gives you a notion of you know this
in this one I have thirty three percent
of errors of this class in here at ten
percent error any questions that's a
quick world wind seven minute tour of
what random forest is about okay so Oh
what we could do is just show you how it
run yes but you combine the trees how do
we combine the trees so we have a bunch
of trees and we just classify
observation with each tree and then you
vote and then you can set the devotee
criteria to what well what percentage
you want so for instance in some cases
you may be interested if you know if you
know the typical thing would be fifty
percent but you may be interested in
cases where there's even a small chance
that you know something is of a
particular class so you can set the
threshold make sense right so how do you
do in with missionary aha so the
question is how to deal with missing
observations well there's um there's two
two things to do that we worry about
missing observation when we build the
trees and then when we valid when we
classify and so a couple of options you
could throw away the rose but that's in
practice really bad because a lot
data set have a lot of missing
observations but it's if you have a data
set that has many features it may turn
out that you actually never visit the
missing observation so what you could do
is say well you know if i get if i
actually try to use a missing
observation at throw away the rope
another thing you could do is if i try
to use a missing observation while I
traverse a tree just randomly pick left
or right you could be more clever and
say well I'm use the distribution of
values in that column others there's a
number of things in our current
implementation we just randomly pick ok
yeah you also randomly sample while
you're building a finger built on random
subset of the available features ah yes
I didn't mention that but yes that is
that is the other but that is another
dark sort of each time each time we we
look at the split we're only evaluating
a subset of the features and I'll come
back to that in a little in a later
slide because it has how many you think
actually has an impact on quality of
your results essentially it is it
using the same kind of command that we
saw earlier simple one jar file one of
the things I asked the team to help just
to make it very easy to deploy I
bootstrap the company teaching Hadoop
one is ready to teach his job or hobby
install it should be kept simple to
install so it's a very simple easy to
install alright that fosters what we're
seeing and not on the main page is
simple tutorial which includes from
Forrester data so this connects you to
the wiki page more about it so it is a
data in jest peace with course coming to
ro HDFS in this one case were important
HDFS let's get us back here how tight is
the worth of most popular
or our most popular data set for the
forest and if you a greater here get a
quick somebody of your bigoted get some
of your data min max missing music mouth
okay that this day is getting forest
coverage type kind of break on a spawn
3054 ten ten no twenty twenty threes or
see the impact so another things you try
to do is to optimize your number face in
traditional are mutations so so cough
stark has about five hundred thousand
rows roughly yeah and here the sorry
we're building the trees incrementally
yes sorry we're building the trees
incrementally as we build the tree we're
building the OB estimate so what what
we're seeing here is the OB estimate
with only part of the trees built and
the page will refresh as we get more
trees the classification error so this
is the aggregate classification error
which sounds a 30-percent and that's
pretty bad typically decreases in this
perfect case so fat some 16 machine
we run more right I'm so if you add
trees you will get a better results and
that sort of the general principle of
random forest right is that putting more
of those weak classifiers together
together gives you better prediction
abilities so so now we're running it for
100 and it's done
so usually on my laptop it takes a
minute or two I have time to talk
through it let's get more bigger data
give your data alright
and ask a quick question so what are the
chances of increasing over by generating
many many more trades so generating many
many more trees would not necessarily
increase over fitting because each one
is built on a distinct subset so so you
don't none of them seized of all data so
they're all sort of wrong okay now what
happens is after while adding trees
doesn't help anymore so I'm depending on
your data set you will see there the
curve of how many trees or what's the
contribution of extreme changes do you
guys have visualizations which means
your urgent oh not at not right now so
this is deal this is the current so we
have 280 eyes y which is the web api and
the other one is an our console that
we're in the process of building them we
will put some of some more smarts in the
console once we have it once your
population yeah so for each memory usage
are you thinking what their over three
or just be icing go to wait for a little
bit i'll tell you all that all oh that's
hot yeah you show
overall I appears so so he switched so
it did yeah so typically the one we have
4 10 3 was was thirty percent which is
quite awful and you can get all the way
to four percent with more trees and
tweaking things of it and i'll mention i
should be able to get better than my
using actors well for the four percent
is the number of errors oh I'm so change
it yes so which one are we doing now I
just need any well it's parsing the big
Gator okay so we're doing several things
at the same time so which which is what
is the big governor to the big deal
right so the big data is the airlines
data that's 12 cake it's not a big big
data set but you know it's bigger than
than the others and we're doing two
things at once fill the building of 103
103 cop type and parsing the airline
late i said it is probably going to take
a little bit because the airline dataset
usually takes a little bit we have to
bring in from this we have to read it a
couple of times and parsing did it
finish
for the system gates we made sure
there's enough stuff in there
but
right so I but I think we got the point
let's go back to the top so yeah so
typically you get confusion matrix like
these and if the trees are small we can
either print them graphically it's a
cute feature but it you know in practice
it's never used because the trees are
big or we can generate Java or C code
that encodes the tree that you can run
you can use in robbing a saucer for
classification and scoring all right so
I said we looked at some other tools
there's a number of implementation or of
RF ours is distributed but we couldn't
get any licensed for another distributed
system so here what we're doing is
comparing the accuracy of different
tools on the single node status there's
a set of you know there's a few data
sets they go from here you know you've
got the stats that roughly said these
are tiny and these are small so small
means hundred thousand to 500,000 rose
tiny means I don't care it's just very
small and so we compared our
implementation the standard our
implementation that bryman did wake up
and wise RF and for each of them I show
the I show the error rate so lower is
better you know we want fewer errors and
the bold numbers are the best for that
particular data set and well you know
the what can we say some sometimes we've
got the best results sometimes
we r you know not too far interestingly
for cough type we get three point six
percent error whereas our gets twenty
two percent that's a really big
difference I don't know why it may be
that our cuts the size of the trees
that's my best guess it was a question
right he's all using the same so the
problem is sometimes we can sometimes we
can't and the random number generators
are different so ya mean a little please
yes yes so so all the other you know all
that note so we can play with are the
same and we try to get for all the tools
the best possible results playing with
different notes to the best mean all I'm
claiming is in two thousand three
thousand lines of code you get a
competitive tool right you know if you
want to spend more time you can do
probably better all right so the
interesting part you know for me as a
computer scientist is well how do we
build this thing how would we built this
this algorithm and you know especially
since it's for a distributed and
parallel setting so it's a couple of
questions so if if your data set doesn't
fit in one computer and you want to
paralyze things there's a couple of
questions you have to answer one of them
is well I said we're going to sample the
data for each tree so imagine I have 12
gigabytes how do i create for a thousand
trees or 500 trees 500 different samples
of cloud gigabytes how do i select the
splits the point at which we are we
perform
we separate the population how do I
Steve ate out of high gear again if I
have to do this on a very large set of
data observations and for many many
treats oh so we have a couple of
insights nothing terribly surprising the
first one is if your data fits in memory
then parallelizing this algorithm is
really really simple right because you
know all of this is very independent so
you can run on you can build your tree
in parallel you can have one thread per
you know your leaf that you're building
and it works very nicely different trees
can be built in parallel again trivially
each tree is independent so you can
build them in parallel now an
interesting observation which we didn't
think of at first is that the tree size
grows a lot so you essentially the trees
are describing all the nooks and
crannies of your data the more complex
the data the more you know some nodes
and branches so trivial datasets small
trees large data sets that they call the
complex function remember the RF only
you know can say oh it's larger or
smaller so you're describing a function
by a sequence of its larger and you know
that that's very a very coarse way to
describe complex functions so if you
have complex data and lots of data your
trees tend to become very large and
lastly if I want to validate a tree you
know can't use my lack of error
out of my error I have to have the tree
together with the data on the same
computer that's obvious well that means
now I have to ship make sure trees are
available on a bus or all these are
things that are you know worth thinking
about when you design an outdoor eating
like this so the strategy we we we
picked is the following we decided to
say well what we'll do is we'll do a
first set of randomization where we
randomize the data over the cluster and
each node has a view of a subset of the
data and it works with that so if we're
building a tree we're going to build it
no local on the subset of the data that
is on that on that note and then you
know we can build treason parallel on
all the nodes and we go we can build we
can build freezing also in parallel with
in a note and then when we want to do
validation we're going to float the
network with trees and these can be you
know easily hundred thousands of split
notes open fairly large so what I'll do
now is I'll just step through some of
the the interesting parts of the
algorithm and tell you how how to do
this so you know the first thing to note
is we're not starting from scratch we're
building on top of the h2o interview
infrastructure and what h2o is good for
is is that it is a good engine for doing
distributed computation so it has two
things it has an abstraction of key
value pairs where values where these are
unique strings and values are vectors
that can span many many notes so first
abstraction yoga abstraction that it has
is it has a distributed for the
framework so in Java there is a notion
of Thor joint friend
work for concurrency and we've added
distribution to it so we can distribute
tasks over the over the cluster and
paralyze them we didn't know so the
question of MapReduce is addressed by a
distributed framework so distributed for
joy means i'm 14 threads and the threads
are migrated silently to different nodes
and they run on those nodes and then
they fork sub threads that are running
on that mode so one way you think about
the h2o system in the long run to think
about it as an operating operating
system for doing distributed
mathematical computations okay it has a
store it has you know threads it has
resource management it has all of this
so for the first bit how do I read and
parse the data well for me it was easy I
just delay differ got to the
infrastructure the infrastructure as a
notion of value array which is like an
our data frame and a very very early has
value array has run rows and columns and
it has a function to read a particular
observation in the valley where the
value array is chumped at four megabytes
chunks and the chunks are randomized
over the network so when I read a big
file 12 gigabyte file that file is
straight through the cluster in four
megabytes units so so parsing stung no
code to write of extracting random
subsets so for extracting random subsets
the strategy we pick to us to say well
what we'll do is we will
have a local cache of data and that
local cache of data will be used it will
be built out of all of the chunks of of
the input array that are no local so
this is done in less than a page here in
h2o so we say this is my data key this
is the name of the file of bars I read
it from the key value store i get a
value array i create a an array of jobs
and then for every four megabytes chunk
that belongs to the value array if it is
located on the current node i create a
job and what the job is is that it will
read all the daytime that value array
and put it in my local cache and then i
invoke all my jobs this runs in parallel
and slurps in all the gold local data in
a representation that I find useful ok
so the caches are in memory and if the
memory starts to if there it starts to
do memory pressures are to increase h2o
will start to evict some of the chunks
to disk so silently there is the Java
garbage collector and the h2o memory
manager from the h2o memory manager
talks to the Java card garbage collector
and when it sees that memory is running
low it starts to push stuff out and if
that's not enough we die ok so the next
interesting bit of the algorithm is of
how to split the data roughly the way
it's described in the briman I our
algorithm is I have this sequence of
values so for if so the way it works is
remember I building
decision tree at each point in the tree
at each node I have some part of the
population and I want to split it in
left and right so imagine that this is
the subset I have at one particular node
in the tree that I'm building what is
the best split so the way right man
describes it is first you sort the
values by you know the feature you're
looking at so this is sorting them in
them in order of increasing value and
then you find the best point where to
split here it's pretty obvious you want
to split here and you get a very nice
red green split but that means sorting
at every node in the tree and every node
sees a different subset of the original
sample day it had so there's not only
not much you can do and you can have all
over a hundred thousand nodes for a big
data sets that's a lot of sorting so
what we do is we turn the data we
discretize the data so for every value
in the original input we turn it in two
consecutive numbers one two three four
and furthermore if we won't prepare some
compaction we will be in a number of
consenting critic value the same same
number and then what we do is then we
don't have to sort because we can just
use an array and store all those values
I think of the those value as indices is
in our urinary and the split function
which I will not detail is this not more
than that and it's basically one big
loop over all the values all the
distinct values in your feature and then
a number of loops over the data and
you're done no sorting nothing just
normal Java easy to write
so it is not cause of wine Johnny
because when you deal with yeah probably
you have a lot of I mean his kingdom
very sad you what he's going to go then
you can be you can aggregate a number of
values into the same same same sin
discrete number at the cost of some
precision you know the choices well do I
want a precision and speed and you know
decree speed or two okay IM dl sorry
something like a dl mdl I mean yeah mini
mod a square shape yes we need to try
anything more than this I since as far
as we got remember not to die beside
these two thousand lines of code it's a
small budget and you know small prey so
and the last bit that I want to mention
is how do we paralyze the tree building
and there it's a simple case of pork
joint and you know this is what boring
code but essentially what you're doing
is for each node you're creating a left
and right and you are going to fork at
red for the left and a forms the thread
for the right now the for joint
framework may not for it will choose
whether it actually forced up but as far
as if the programmers go you know you
consider that you forked and you forget
about it and that's proper probably all
I have to say about the implementation
so while building this we found a number
of fun observations one of them that of
Java is a very very you know pleasant
language to work with it has lots of
libraries that I've
is are very good there is a random
number generated class and that render
random number isn't very rented okay and
it showed up in surprising ways we were
getting bad air race right so it
actually so so so our the quality of our
result was like twice as worse as our
and this was just because a random
number generator was returning sequences
that were not at random also we fixed we
implemented our own regular your
generator than we realize that the the
some random number generator is ok as
long as the seed is really big so now
that's a good thing to know yeah healthy
ah basically it has to be along and you
use you know enough of the bits it's
open source cook there is a we it's
documented exactly how much we had to do
add um three size gets to be a challenge
dick trees are hundreds of kilobytes
hundreds of megabytes that's a point
it's not one regards up to a megabyte if
you have lots of them it becomes a
problem I said that we randomized by
spreading for megabyte chunks and using
all the chunks that are on the node but
that means our randomization is only at
four megabytes boundaries which is not
great and that's a engineering thing
which we should just fix randomized a
much better and then last thing to do
that as a message for anybody building
things like that build the algorithm so
it is deterministic yes it's a random
algorithm make it sure that you have a
mode where you can repeat and get
exactly the same result so it's already
hard enough the thing with statistics
you always get a number 42
remember or a bad number it's 42 no no
you asked the domain people they'll tell
you what 42 is a great number and I can
give you an explanation why we said you
come a week later it said actually it
was 24 oh I can give you an explanation
one yes so really hard testing is
important so that's tiny bit of of this
tube is we played a little bit with the
knobs of the algorithm this is just
telling you which nodes are interesting
and worth looking at so we have these
data sets this is about cough type which
is describing forests as I said we have
500,000 rose and typically we use
300,000 for model building and 200,000
for validation so the first thing we did
was we varied the sampling rate so this
is from 0 to 100 and the sampling rate
is how much of the observation do I use
to build each tree right um it's a it's
a bite question how much should i use
right could use one percent and then i
get errors that are really too high or i
could could use a hundred percent and
for type it seems that the more i
use the more my blue line is the
validation error the better i get
results but it's not the case for all
all all all other data sets and the red
line here is out of bagger and it's sort
of interesting that as you use you have
more and more of your your your data
that is used to build each tree the out
of bag error becomes meaningless and why
well because it has so few observation
that it becomes very chaotic but the
rest of the curve they follow each other
fair
nicely so the output bagair is a good
predictor of your actual error so the
other thing we played for was so
somebody asked about this number of
feature / split so the algorithm each
time it evaluates a split doesn't look
at the whole set of feature but only a
subset and how many of them you pick
matters so here what we are showing is
blue is our classification error and we
show this shows this is the error rate
this is the number of features you use
so cough type has 50 features so we get
a loose from one feature all the way to
50 and this the different lines are four
different sampling rates but let's take
the bottom one the bottom one is for an
eighty percent sampling rate so you see
that as I increase the number of feature
my error decreases and then around you
know 30 or so which is about half I get
the best result and then it it it it
becomes worse and what this sort of
suggest is you know again overfitting
right to see too much of the data I'm
overfitting another fun thing to do with
cough type is you can drop out certain
features completely and you see that for
instance so this is these are the
feature numbers and this is the impact
of dropping one of them so if I drop
feature zero my error goes to eight
percent so worse error that feature is
really useful but if I drop out feature
one my error goes by 24 four-point-five
percent so feature one is actually
confusing your algorithm right so the
more data doesn't mean the better
results all right so come into the end
so what did we see with so random for
asset cool horrible machine learning
algorithm my claim is it's actually easy
to write a distribute
hood and parallel implementation if you
have the right tools right it's not that
hard it took a couple of months to get
it right but you know if I have to do it
again in a couple of weeks different
implementation choice are definitely
possible so the way we're building
things you know we're doing this siloing
of the data per node that is just a
choice and you know whether it performs
better or not and some other
implementation that remains to be
evaluated and you know for us I think we
want to scale two terabyte data you know
to see whether does it's very likely
that when you scale up the current
approach won't work it's just too much
data trees will be too big so what do we
do and you know I don't know we need to
actually see real data to be able to
tell that's pretty much all i have to
say for today thank you for your
attention any question
right so the models the trees are stored
as key value pairs in the in the cloud
value store and you can any can request
them by providing forestry and there is
then there's an aggregate for the whole
forest yes so if you're a fan of
programming languages why didn't you use
scholar to the job it will be 200 lines
instead of two thousand and it'll be two
times slower books who cares about
performance no I shall I just you know
Scylla is a wonderful language spent six
months with parting on their ski about
seven years ago previous sabbatical it
is a language that dangerously pushes
the limits of human understandability in
its type system I work with are our has
no types I find that no useful and handy
and so I don't know it's just
familiarity it was question here how
many more lives are good to do or face
regression right so regression we
haven't implemented and our belief is
not that hard but so this is you know
the usual thing in computer science yeah
let's feature no problem years later oh
well yeah so I guess my question is kind
of in two parts can you give us a sense
given how much data data it is on a
single note how much memory footprint is
like what the ratio is number two given
the size of a data set how much
computing resources doing me to train
with your implementation of a random
yeah so the two questions where how much
memory you know if I have let me
rephrase that if I have one gigabyte of
memory per node how much keep do I need
to provision for the job of year
preferred very how much what is the
limit in the size of the data that can
be processed as well the limit is
clearly how many gigabytes of RAM you
health and we we typically we require
about say twice 2.5 as much heat as the
data okay so you know we running on 500
gigabyte EBEs but you know that's tends
to be expensive the other question was
the speed at which it would yeah given a
data set let's say it's you know 100
gigs on how many how many knows how many
hid eight what is that configuration
have to look like so usually we have
wrong you know so it depends on what you
have right so we have run with 16 course
10 cake notes and you know for a hundred
cakes it will be probably in the 20s or
so depends because we compress the data
as we parse it so the 100 games may end
up being much smaller if we're lucky and
the other thing is the complexity of the
data is going to drive a lot of the
speed and space costs so imagine that
you're all of your observations are
completely different there is no
redundancy then your tree will be the
size of your your you know as many lee
as rose not good right but the hope is
that we're looking for patterns are that
we can collapse things this is you know
this is the interesting question how far
can we and what we've seen is up to now
it that the bigger data set the bigger
trees and the bigger tree is the more
accurate so whenever we cut down on
three sides by imposing a limit we lose
on accuracy and that becomes a very hard
problem right because you really like
that accuracy but it costs and you know
that's a trade-off that depends on what
your end goals are and in order data
service so I you know the depth or just
a number of those you could have a very
deep single line read which will be fine
it's the number of leads that matters
for
whether we're building facilities to cut
down the branching factor so one of the
things we're doing is like bidding some
of the values we're so decreasing the
number of distinct observables and that
will decrease your ranging factor at the
cost of precision and that's the only
thing we've come up with so far this is
one ? advisor the trees yeah my
understanding is one of the trade-offs
that your dog or to do is have weaker
classifiers smaller trees yeah I just
have a lot of work welcome solitude so
yeah I can speak to that a little bit so
the question is well wouldn't it be just
better to say have small trees but
millions and the problem with that is
often since the depends on your data set
but imagine that your data set has many
features the likelihood at the top of
the tree none of those feature will
select very well so you won't pick
random features and they'll cut the
population in half randomly without
really increasing the information
content in each of the partition and
it's only when you start to go down to
smaller sets that you start picking up
information so my intuition is that
artificially cutting down the depth of
the tree really really hurts you
especially for large data sets I and I
don't have a good answer because it
sucks lot larger trees are really
expensive those accuracy
so if okay Jeannie didn't forget was
better than Jeannie pretty much in all
our data sets not by much but yeah since
I had it implemented in forgetting I
kept that one and throughout the other
did you do any variable importance you
display oh so we haven't implemented
that it's you know he's easily done
close to two thousand nine so what we
have any waffle fail ha good question so
issue is an operating system that is not
yet fault-tolerant so currently if you
lose a node it's just like you lose a
little bit of you run bad things happen
you know we we have plans to make things
more folks who aren't but it's unclear
that the extra costs the costs are worth
it so a lot of our computations are done
in matters of minutes and the feeling is
you know if we can keep you know down
two minutes and just rerun the thing
with your nose if we get to the point
where you're running twenty-four seven
with one cloud that stays up that's a
different proposition you know different
engineering choices will have to be made
a fool of aggression type the patient
has
no we don't do that yet oh he doesn't
mean regression but part yeah hella hard
yes sir no we are haven't implemented
its ash research it's part of our
roadmap my sabbatical is anything that
will be his problem going to finish it
first yeah any other questions
and you can tell young so yeah good
happy to go distinctly of university and
running beyond was present being at
Stanford and said young icon found
villainous for us in our it's just too
damn slow and oh sure lucky he kept his
word k and join me on a sabbatical and
build a fantastic random forest this is
all 20 years of being said I remember a
line 20 years later dead and i think
this proliferation like a second we do
we run it but random forest is when it
taught us a lot anything it was the
first i'll go be built and the took two
months extracted its cost but the core
platform has gotten so much better well
well he's running this I'll say if you
want to build something like the earth
like this platform what is the hardest
problem ever the hardest problem is
parsing the data if you can show in Java
the joke was if you can run hello world
you have implemented Java here if you
can parse distributed uncompress from s3
do you know on the fly in memory
compression you're good everything else
is easy it's no different from your day
to day life where one thing is
the questions of design so yeah we have
a pretty very good robust road map
actually GBM is coming up here we have a
very good gala thanks to rob and Trevor
put up the road back here but this
format is a function of the number of
users who have asked us things so this
is not a static or times they actually
put from customers and users and
community and no product is complete
without the community and especially in
the open source we want you guys to
chime in on what you need if GBM is your
next big problem pick it up or personal
machine come out but we pick what we
have is on the left most part and we
actually have run in Forest 80mm which
is a latest technique from Sanford that
gives us ways to do but does it talk
tomorrow on on some of that stuff and
next weekend and week after would be
really are you to the community channel
what we want to do with the platform
it's it's a first step we have some big
offers but you want to make sure it
actually does salsa vehicle horns here's
the 20 year gala it is uplifting
airlines are like more than 98 thinking
maybe there's a couple of more columns
to
random forest definitely goes after some
years more dear you have better it gets
so that sends we get an enforcer at a
match made in heaven and and so so if
the system can scale you guys have a
fantastic corporate tool you don't go
back to understand a global to take back
to your own implementation in your own
day and make a fantastic impact but so
one more case in point of finally one
picked up this is not the end for an
important beginning its kind of useful
but we need the people talk about very
importance that comes up riding on a
road map you will want regressions
cartridge and that's a fantastic request
so this road map pieces people who are
capable can contribute or just chime on
issues or think that you want anyone
make sure even if John's going back on
sabbatical he's these his some
facilities are really buildings of the
core cut the ends of Safari and other
productive things that he reducing so it
is a prolific producer of great
engineers thanks young and thank you for
coming you have any further questions